hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in her article the trolley problem from
section
five onward judith jarvis thompson
is going to frame these cases in terms
of
rights and she's going to develop a more
and more
sophisticated analysis of that
pointing out the need to look at
important
factors and not just generalize from the
notion
of rights per se she says that there's
two facts about the bystander at the
switch the
now familiar version of the trolley
problem that you see
in most of the memes where you've got
somebody who actually has to pull a
switch
which will take the runaway trolley from
the track where it's going to run down
five people
and shunt it on to another track where
it will instead
kill one and thompson says that we
we may do this this is morally
permissible it's not morally
required but it certainly is okay
in other cases like that of surgeon or
the transplant or hospital we
we don't see a similar you know it's
okay to sacrifice
one for five kind of result coming in
from at least most people and she says
that there's there's two important
considerations here that have to do with
the one case as opposed to the others
two facts she says about which he does
what he does which seemed to me to
explain the moral difference
between what he does in the bystander at
the switch and what the agent and
transplant would be doing if he
proceeded in the first place
the bystander saves his five by making
something that threatens them instead of
threaten
one we're going to come back to that
second the bystander does not do that
by means which themselves constitute an
infringement
of any right of the one and so this is
where we
want she says we want to make an appeal
to the concept of a right
and she says my feeling is that solving
this problem
requires making appeal to that concept
or to some other concept
that does the same kind of work
and that's interesting so she says that
in a footnote i strongly suspect giving
an account of what makes it wrong to use
a person
would also require an appeal to the
concept of a right so
even a conscient approach isn't going to
do it for her
instead she talks about one of the great
20th century theorists of rights
ronald dwarken and his metaphor
from bridge a card game could
equally apply to pie knuckle or
to sheepshead or any other game in which
you have
trumps he says rights trump
utilities what does that mean so
utilities
are when we're thinking about the
overall
distribution of benefits and harms and
trying to
maximize benefits and minimize
harm so utilitarian reasonings about
things that he's just calling that
utilities and she
follows using that so she says that is
one would infringe a right in
or by act if one would infringe a right
in or by acting then it is not
sufficient justification
that one would thereby maximize utility
so
we can in fact maximize utility and
ought to maximize utility in most cases
unless somebody's right is being
infringed thereby so
you could think of this as something
that is superimposed upon our normal
moral processes of maximizing utility
so if we do that then we have to
look for who has rights and it seems
like
in the bystander at the switch we have a
right don't we
doesn't pulling the switch infringe on
the
one work men's right to life
you know it certainly seems that way and
in the surgeon thing we
we could say the the right the young man
has against the surgeon that the surgeon
not kill him
a right in the cluster of rights that
the young man has
in having a right to life having a right
to life means
having a right not to be killed right so
what about this worker out there on the
track that you're going to have the
trolley
run over and
she says in bystander at the switch the
reason why the bystander
may proceed this is what some people
might say is that if he does proceed he
maximizes utility he brings about a net
saving of four lives
and in so doing he does not infringe on
any right of the one
track workmen's and she says well is
that really the case
is it clear the bystander would infringe
no right of the one-track workman if he
turned the trolley suppose there weren't
anybody on the straight track
and the bystander turned the trolley
onto the right-hand track killing the
one but not saving anybody
wouldn't that infringe a right of the
one workman what's the
the right there a right in the cluster
of rights he has in having a
right to life so putting five other
people on the track
that you're gonna hit it doesn't take
away that right now does it
that's a good point but maybe we could
say well
you know they're work people so
therefore there's some sort of
waving of the right to life
they when they enter the workplace they
know it's going to be a dangerous place
right she says that we must make room
for this possibility of waiving a right
and went into that category
for the possibility of failing to have a
right
by virtue of assumption of risk it might
be argued that that that is exactly
what's involved here
the track workmen know the risks of the
job and consent to run them
when signing on for it and she says
that's not a very good way of resolving
this difficulty
track workmen certainly do not
explicitly consent to being run down
with trolleys when doing so will save
five who are on some other
track certainly they're not asked to
consent to this at the time of signing
on for the job
and i doubt they would consciously
assume the risk of it at that
or any other time and what if they're
not track workmen what if you've got
as she says uh young children or what if
they'd been people shoved out of
helicopters
wouldn't it it all the same be
permissible to turn the trolley so
this waving rights that's not gonna work
that's that's not gonna help us here
so she goes on in the next section
and says
that maybe we need to attend to
the means by which one kills and
saves not just whether people have
rights not just the decision
that's being made and she says this is
where these two crucial facts
are important in bystander at the switch
we save the five by making something
that threatens them
instead threaten the one and we
don't do that by means which themselves
constitute infringements or the right of
the ones
so she said let's let's look at this
first thing
a little bit more closely if the surgeon
precedes a transplant
is it the same kind of situation he is
not
saving his five by making something that
threatens them
instead threaten one they are going to
die of organ failure
and the young man who's going to be
carved up for his organs
against his consent is going to die you
could say well
it's organ failure no it's the organs
are actually taken
out of his body producing his death
they're taking his you know
heart and lungs and and kidneys so yeah
that'll kill you
right so it's not like
making a trolley go from one track to
another or
a fire or an avalanche or poison gas
that you have to divert from one part of
the hospital
into another where instead of killing
five it kills one in this case
the means that kill the person are
different
than the danger to the other people
and thompson thinks that this is
very relevant she talks as well as where
she introduces the case of
hospital there are five patients in a
hospital whose lives could be saved by
the manufacture of a gas
but this will inevitably release lethal
fumes into the room of another patient
who are unable to move and you know she
says
we can't do that but if we're dealing
with
gas that's already in the system you
know
and we have to divert it one way or
another we can do that so
the means are very important and this
this qualification
of making something threaten the one
instead of threatening the five this is
is what the trolley case
in her view is about and this means
that we're engaged in doing something
that's a little bit
different she says what does the
bystander do
he doesn't merely minimize the number of
deaths that get caused
there's two key things here he minimizes
the number of deaths
which get caused by something that
already
threatens people and that will cause
deaths whatever the bystander does so
there somebody is going to die no matter
what
and the deaths are you could say
on the same causal
level or in the same causal chain
however you want to frame it
this allows uh in in
thompson's view what she calls a
distributive exemption to be
made which permits arranging that
something that will do harm
anyway shall be better distributed than
it otherwise
would be shall do harm to fewer rather
than
more and she says not just any
distributive invention is permissible
it's not
generally morally open to us to make one
die to save five
but other things being equal it is not
morally required of us that we let a
burden descend out of the blue onto five
when we
can make it instead descend onto
one now the question that we can ask
here is
is this infringing on somebody's
rights or is when she says exemption
does she mean well
they don't really have a right at that
point and we can
understand this a little bit better when
we think about some of the
cases that apply to this this question
of infringing uh
somebody's right and so this is where
she introduces the fat man
example the fat man instead of the
trolley
you know being diverted by a switch or
the driver deciding on it
you are on a bridge and there's a fat
guy watching the trolley proceeding
towards uh five workers five people tied
down to the tracks
and you could push him over his mass is
sufficient
that when the trolley hits him it will
stop
but you are pushing him
to his death and she actually considers
a couple
variations well what if you don't
actually push him
what if you just notice that the hand
rail is kind of wiggly
and he's leaning on the handrail
watching the trolley
and all you need to do is like give the
handrail a little tap
and then it'll it'll break and he'll
fall down she says
in these cases we would say no you
cannot
do that why because you are using
a means that infringe the rights
of the fat man in the one case the means
is you're using the fat man himself
as the means to stop the trolley
right to save the five and you're you're
using means that definitely infringe
upon his right to life
in the handrail example it's a little
bit trickier and and we'll come to that
so
she says here um
suppose the agent proceeds he shows the
fat man toppling off the footbridge
causing him to be hit by the trolley
thereby killing him saving the five
this agent does so by means that by
themselves
constitute an infringement of the right
of the ones shoving a person
is infringing a right of his so is
toppling a person off a footbridge
and she says i should stress that doing
these things is infringing a person's
rights even if doing them does not cause
his death
even if doing them causes no harm at all
as i shall put it shoving a person
toppling a person off a footbridge
are themselves infringement of rights
now if it's not going to cause death
just a little scare maybe we would say
well in this case it's not that big of a
deal
but she goes on and says consider by
contrast the agent and bystander at the
at the switch he too if he proceeds
saves five by making something that
threatens them
instead threaten one but the means he
takes are these turn the trolley
off onto the right-hand track turning
the trolley is not an infringement of
anybody's rights by itself and this is
where she brings up the wobbly
railing and she says what i have in mind
is a rather tighter notion of means
by hypothesis wobbling the handrail will
cause the fat man to topple into the
track
but the trolley will not threaten him
instead of the five unless
wobbling the handrail does cause him to
topple getting the trolley to threaten
the f the fat man
instead of the five requires getting him
into the path by whatever means i mean
you could also say insulting him so that
he falls off the track
out of outrage and embarrassment would
be using a means as well that would
produce that that effect
right so she goes on and she says
i had a notion of means that comes out
as follows
um suppose you get a trolley to threaten
one instead of five by
wobbling a handrail the means you take
to get the trolley to threaten the one
include
wobbling the handrail and all those
further things you have to succeed in
but by by wobbling it if the trolley is
to threaten the one instead of the five
so the means by which the agent and fat
man gets the trolley to threaten
one instead of five include toppling the
fat men off the footbridge this is an
infringement right
she does also clarify what kind of
infringement
an infringement of a stringent right of
the one
or the few a particularly stringent
right she says when we say stringent we
mean
a right that really has to take priority
over others and so she says consider a
few other cases
what if the bystander at the switch has
to cross without permission
a patch of land that belongs to the one
in order to get to the switch
thus in order to get the trolley to
threaten the one instead of the five the
bystander must infringe a right of the
ones
may he proceed or what if he has to use
a sharply pointed tool
and the only available sharply pointed
tool is a nail file that belongs to the
one
here to the bystander must infringe a
right of the ones
in order to get the trolley to threaten
the one instead of the five may he
proceed
so he's already infringing rights these
are not particularly stringent though
she says that the rights which the
bystander would have to infringe here
are
minor trivial non-stringent
property rights of no great importance
by contrast
the right not to be toppled off a
footbridge onto a trolley track is a
stringent right so there's an
important difference between stringent
and minor
trivial non-stringent rights that
applies
here as as well and so she says that
what is at work here is a matter of
degree and it should be no surprise
that there are borderline cases on which
people
do in fact disagree
but she goes on and she says in any case
the distributive exemption that we spoke
of earlier
is very conservative it permits
intervention into the world to get an
object that already threatens death to
those
many to instead threaten death to these
few
only by acts that are not themselves
gross
impingements on the few that is the
intervener must
not use means that infringe stringent
rights of the few so we can use means
that do
infringe rights of the few they cannot
be
you know uh violating stringent rights
and and this
is for her the solution to the problem
and the way to clarify
how it is that rights come in here
how we should understand them
in these tricky moral dilemmas
you